these handhold gaming PCs have proven to
be the next step in our portable gaming
Journey the PSP was insane back then but
now with the Lenova Legion go and RG
hitting shells our tiny Minds would have
melted we've got two sides of the coin
here with the Lenova Legion grow coming
in with a larger screen a touchpad
that's definitely an improvement over
the steam decks and an interesting
approach to FPS gaming with their joycon
like controllers the Rog allies are
relatively smaller form factor without
the touchpad two macro button to the
back and it's focused on delivering
reliable gaming where youi roam under
the hood they're exactly the same they
both run AMD ryzen Z1 extreme chips with
rdna or integrated AMD Graphics 16 gigs
of RAM and they both have 512 gigs of
storage now where they majorly differ is
in the screen size and type like it's
not obvious enough with Rog going down
the 16x9 route it's a 7in 1080p full HD
IPS 120 HZ 16x9 display with adaptive
sync on the other end the Lenovo Legion
go is in the 16 X10 Park 8.8 in in IPS
qu HD Plus 144 HZ monitor also their
battery capacities are 40 W hour for the
Ali and 49.2 W hour for the legion grow
obviously they are two different but
almost evenly matched beast in the same
ring so the start of the fight we're
going to go off with the older of the
two fighters I have to make a note and
say that because they're both packing MD
or Z1 or Z1 extremes depending on what
you go with you and I kind of expect
these to run current and NX gen Triple A
those like but because they're not RX
7900s or they're Nvidia equivalent RTX
490s for those that are new to this
genre of consoles as I'd like to call it
most enthusiasts really use these
handheld PCS for emulators older games
older AAA games and sometimes current
gen AAA games but bringing everything
down by a a couple notches and by a
couple I mean like a lot the RG Li from
pre-launch to dday of its release has
had the smoothest journey in terms of
updates and stability between the two in
my opinion and I enjoy playing with it
on the goal with its form factor and how
light it is at 68 G of course i' say
with its design the only Pitfall is the
lack of a solid back grip at the back
here it's not a deal breaker for me but
as I mentioned before in an earlier
review that if by some chance they
release another version I really love a
slight ergonomic upgrade to the bottom
half of the bag at least a little more
coverage will make a world of a
difference for me because with the
hardware it's packing and it's small F
factor and wait it's so easy to bring
around especially if you're planning to
you know bring this overseas emulators
and some AAA games like cyber Punk and C
monare 3 can be played on this with some
tweaking and play even better when
plugged in obviously overall the Ally is
proven to be the go-to H out PC for many
out there and before we continue this
channel is supported by Brands who help
us improve our content and keep us going
so stick around for this sponsored
message here at geek culture we've
tested plenty of chairs but Secret Life
gaming chairs remain one of our
favorites whether it's for work or play
they feel great to lean back against
with the ergonomic features offering
support for the whole body from the head
and back to the arms and even something
for your but this mix of fourman
function helps the Titan Evo 2022
deliver the best seating experience like
no other for more information check out
secretlab.co where the Ally is pretty
much a PSP in my head the legion go is
the love child between a steam deck and
Nintendo switch with an interesting
genetic Boon I mean the FPS mod it's
much larger has way more buttons and
feels great in hand again this runs the
same specs as the Allies so honestly
they play the same sa for the preset
power settings which you can tweak to
your liking of course at the time of
recording this is still pretty new so
when it comes to Performance and just
optimization in general we're going to
have to wait for a bit longer to get
more recent games running smoother so
that's how I'm me to getting its
performance for now if you want to get a
little taste of it gameplay just watch
our other video here how does it feel
playing with this it has a bigger screen
and a very pretty one at that that
displays games and videos like
beautifully it speakers honestly not
that bad but of course they plucked or
connected with earphones earbuds
headphones you know and there are like
seven buttons on this thing with three
macros at the back if you remove the
legion true strike controllers like what
I'm doing right now you've got a mouse
in the form of the right controll that
magnetically connects to this dock over
here just like this and it's effectively
a mouse with mouse one and mouse two and
a scroll and the left controller can be
used movement when you're playing games
I will say that as someone that
primarily plays fpss the FPS mode is
kind of jarring and it will feel kind of
weird trying to get into it especially
if you're trying to play competitive
games like called mod Warfare 3 off the
bat you're going to be in for a really
bad time like an astronomically bad time
you can play with FPS mode but it's
going to take a while to get used to it
I recommend it for single player games
like cyberpunk 2077 but again you're
going to need time to get used to
playing with this mode it's a great idea
with a bit of a skill curve but but the
best part about this Legion go is that
it gives you options on how to play the
games because honestly the handheld
version is fine and I can get a great
grip when I'm playing however over
prolonged periods of time you will feel
your hands getting a little numb because
it is definitely a bigger fell and it
weighs around 854 G your hands will
definitely feel it even if you support
your arms in any kind of way you will
feel its weight over a prolonged period
of time then the third mode is a
tabletop mode that the legion go offers
you by opening up the kickstand like
what I'm doing right now and by removing
both controls you can put the monitor or
the display on the table and then just
start gaming like this in the same way
you game with a controller which again I
know will feel kind of weird when you're
playing with this thing but
honestly yeah once you get used to it
you're golden also I don't know if it's
just me but the legion go feels like
it's made of buttons not that it's an
issue that affect gameplay but when you
grip the sides it feels kind of weird
touching so many buttons so that's
something I like to point out and note
down besides all that I really like the
touch pad and have the feedback I get
from it and the whole console when I
play games the best comparison for
handfield I can give the legion girl is
the PS5 dual sense controller it feels
really good in hand especially with the
way the controller set up so for a first
entry from Lenovo the legion go is
definitely getting a lot of things right
also I have to say that I really love
the entire look I kind of wish the Alli
went with a black console as well
instead of the white cuz you know
obviously you can see all the dirt but
with this it looks beautiful and I'll
see the build quality feels pretty
premium the kickand takes quite a bit of
force to push it down and yeah it's it's
really a pretty console but the only
thing that I will point out is that the
back over here this material is quite
the fingerprint magnet so just be
mindful of that it really picks up a lot
of fingerprints now the Ally and Legion
go are great consoles in their own
rights but in terms of portability I
would have to give it to the the Ally
because the legion go is huge and so is
its case which is over there God damn it
one second so here is it
case this
thing that's the case you can definitely
bring it with you on a hand carry and
anywhere else provided your bag or you
know you have a free hand to hold this
thing but the idea that I can put my
ally in pretty much any bag without
having to Think Twice The Ally shines in
that respect in terms of the butons of
both of them the legion go feels better
in the fact that they don't wobble as
much the r Ally does if you can hear
that yeah that's how much wobble there
is in that thing and if you hear the
legion
go it's not as much it's pretty much
stay in place compared to
this
yeah y so a point goes to Lenovo the
analog sticks on both of them feel
smooth and they're large so they fit
most if not all fingers one thing I like
to note is that the Ally has thicker
rubber caps so we'll have to see how we
and tear affects both of them in the
long run and with a thicker cap my money
is on the Ally but like you know just
get protect this for the analog sticks I
think if you're looking to get a
handheld gaming PC right away you go
with the Ali but if you're willing to
wait things out a little more for Lenovo
and developers to ease and smooth out
the performance of the Legion goal you
should definitely get the legion goal if
you have the patience for it The Ally is
solely focused on bringing PC gaming on
the goal with the F factor and weight to
boot but the legion go will give you
options in how you play and that's three
options by the way so you can add a
little spice to your gaming sessions
personally I would go with the Ally
because I carry around a lot of
equipment but I know many of you out
there will want the options that you get
with the legion go if you have any
questions about either let me know in
the comments below and if you like what
we do maybe follow us on all of our
socials we put our content every single
day and maybe hit the like And subscribe
buttons it goes a long way this has been
Zen have a great week and I'll catch
youall soon
oh